I had a line you sucked with that mouth
I just laughed just now repeating it to
you so that one we had a lot of takes on
that one
I only saw feelings I like that great
title
[Laughter]
I mean hanging on the hood of the car is
hard after a while I'm rollerblading up
a hill in a scene you think I chose I'm
rollerblading up that hill like you know
a few times it was easy to stay in shape
while making this movie there was never
a point making this movie where I
thought we didn't go far enough I'd have
sex with a 19 year old for a Buick it'd
be so easy Jean and I were both really
on the same page about wanting to kind
of push that envelope when you look at
it you tweak it you talk about it and
you know it's just kind of like it's
always like a moving kind of living
organism it just kept making us laugh
the spigot that's the gas wait what's
the what is it the guess what I don't
have one either and that was kind of
like what we had set out to do this
situation alone of the movie just caused
so much laughter all day every day you
know like if I was like looking out of
the ocean and like tearing up and Jean
would just be like and then she decides
will she the boy for the Buick or not